did you know that he soaked his Bungie
gum has the properties of both rubber
and subscribing to this channel
in fact it's by far the most overpowered
known ability in the entire series and
you can be just like you soca simply by
subscribing to this channel hello and
welcome to the new world review your
source for everything anime and manga
and today it's time to get slightly
gruesome with one of the strongest
narrative devices that hunter hunter is
capable wielding being shocking deaths
so one of the things I absolutely love
about the series is that at any given
time I never feel like any character is
100% safe and that is a very very
difficult thing to achieve a nation and
genre specifically but Hunter Hunter has
been able to set this atmosphere by
making it very clear early on that this
series is not afraid to permanently
remove characters on a whim and often
before it feels like they have really
come to fruition in the story and today
I figured we don't as some of these more
shocking departures with the criteria
for this list being fairly obvious but
essentially a character needs to have
died to be featured here and a good
argument needs to be made in regards to
why we may not have necessarily have
expected them to pass on prior to their
ultimate moment in this world also all
deaths on today's list will be taken
exclusively from Hunter hunter canon so
no movie fun times oh and obviously this
video is going to contain at least five
potential spoilers if you are new to
Hunter hunter so please do watch at your
own risk but with that out of the way
let's begin
welcome to the top 5 most shocking
deaths in Hunter hunter number 5 pockle
alright we're commencing this list with
one of the most horrific deaths in the
series in my opinion fated to occur to
the ever loveable pockle I mean I say
loveable but the thing about pockle is
that he was always kind of a nothing
character like he had a pretty cool
presence during many elements of the
hunter exam but in the end he did kind
of coast his way to becoming a hunter
and then just sort of faded into the
background afterwards I mean not without
exchanging home codes without
protagonist thus potentially setting up
a return sometime in the future and he
was briefly mentioned during heavens
arena when winged was discussing who and
gorn's graduating class new nen so I
think had always felt like pockle even
though he was almost purely a background
character who was being kept for
something more than what he got and to
get into that paços eventual comeback
would occur during the Chimera ant arc
only to end up being completely
outclassed by an ant officer by the name
of Pike and being taken back to the nest
alive all of this is to be expected so
father I mean Paco is an established
you see character at the stage so he's
surely going to survive that oh wait no
he gets lobotomized butchered and served
to the Chimera ant queen oh wow and
that's not to say that Paco didn't serve
a grand purpose in fact he very much was
responsible for providing the chimera
ants with the information they needed to
properly wield nen more so than even
that there are pakal's death set the
tone for the entire arc with someone so
loveable just being brutally murdered in
front of our eyes showing the sheer
cruelty of the chimera ants in
retrospect it was a very necessary
narrative sacrifice was I expecting it
though well absolutely not
number four gato so by this stage in the
story I really feel like I should not
have been as surprised by this death as
I was but well here we are I guess the
thing about gato is that he was subject
to the same sort of effect as Paco
because gato was introduced into the
series very very early on in the grand
scheme of things and despite the fact
that he really had not done anything
since the zoldak family arc he had this
error of established character about him
and I didn't really go into this too
much with Paco
but this is a very important aspect of
crafting a shocking death because
basically in a more pedestrian series
when a death is necessary and author
will introduce a new character just
prior to that event needing to happen
with the intention that would be that
character who finds that demise which
ends up lessening the overall effect of
the death significantly meanwhile
characters who survive long enough
especially in a series like this gain a
sort of perceived plot armor the idea
that while we've come this far with them
they sure they can't die now and that is
when the narrative device of death can
hit very very potently looking back on
it with gato I really should not have
expected anything less after beginning
and engagement with Hisoka this mad
magician is known almost exclusively for
killing and yeah gato was good with
coins and stuff that he Sokka is one of
the most terrifying forces to be
reckoned with in all of hunter hunter
and yet when he Sokka did slice gatos
neck wide open I could not help feel
that I really just couldn't believe what
I was seeing I mean this was gato I met
him so long ago I really liked him and
now he's gone for no really great reason
either I mean yes he ultimately played a
part in kill about being able to revive
gone but it felt like this Butler had so
much left to do as the most prominent
servant of the zoldak family his death
wasn't flagged in any way and it didn't
derive any great benefit for us going
forward and I guess that is the kind of
futility that is part of what makes it
so shocking and realistic it one
again showed me just how brutal this
world is because apparently I do need
constant reminders as I keep expecting
established characters to make it out of
any situation in one piece and I really
really should not number 3G to so of all
of the deaths on today's list I'd say
that this one is certainly the least
tragic but no less shocking of course I
mean throughout his entire run of the
series cheeto was practically begging
for the sweet embrace of death by
consistently throwing himself into
high-level combative situations and
completely misusing Nan abilities
granted to him and that's quite a shame
because Cheechoo had amazing potential
as a fighter but in the anti very much
served as an ultimate example of how not
to use nen but even with all of this in
mind for him to die when he did was
sudden and impactful being killed with a
single strike from a surprise cameo
appearance from one silver zoldak and I
would argue that it was a great shock
because cheeto had become quite a
fixture during the Chimera and talked
this annoying antagonist whose constant
comedic struggles with life and almost
gotten to a point where they were quite
charming it would not have surprised me
at all if two two had lived on past this
arc but if he did have to die then it
really did feel like it was set up to be
at the hands of one of the extermination
team like moral or knuckle who were
effectively established rivals of Chi 2
and in a more standard ly structured
Shonen story one of them surely would
have been the figure to take him out and
actually you know what even Xena would
have been a more prime candidate in my
mind to carry out the task given how Chi
2 was trying to provoke him but this is
just the brilliance of Takashi setting
up expectations and then dashing them
but in a really great way because there
was something so satisfying about the
shock of seeing silver dispatched Chi to
with a single blow that at once signaled
a rightful end of an ant who bit off far
more than he could chew whilst also
reminding us of just how much of a
powerhouse the zoldak family really is
number 2 Hisoka right so remember
previously when discussing gato I stated
that he Sokka was one of the most
terrifying forces to be reckoned with in
all of hunter hunter well that belief
also happens to be exactly why his death
in the series came as one of the most
startling moments to me as a reader and
to be fair he was in Heaven's arena
battling to the death again scroller so
perhaps this should not have been
entirely unexpected but at the same time
up until this point he selca had been a
pillar of this universe this sword of
force of unwavering power in menace and
while he obviously wasn't the strongest
being we'd ever met he was still
powerful enough to the
where it seems like nothing could take
him down in fact when you think about it
it took Crowell Oh such an incredible
effort to defeat the magician not so
much in terms of the actual fight but
with all of the planning and mental
ingenuity put into nailing down exactly
how to deal with someone like Hisoka and
Corolla made it look easy but this was a
gargantuan effort and even then until
the moment in question happened I was
still expecting Hisoka to pull something
out and probably not like win the match
of course but at the very least secure
his survival and well I was somewhat
wrong about that because the time came
and there lay Hisoka confirmed dead and
yes he did manage to engage in
post-mortem meant to revive himself at
the fact that he died in the first place
well it hit me pretty damn hard I might
also be quite biased lured because he
Sokka is admittedly one of my favorite
characters in the series so even when
things looked inevitable against Crowe
lo I was probably just hoping against
hope for the best
although I'd argue that through a
shocking death toh gosh she gave me
something even better than anything that
could have happened if he Sokka had
simply escaped so this is yet another
example of an untimely death being used
to narrative advantage however we still
have yet to examine our top contender
number one kite so a number one place
today is probably quite predictable and
if anybody ever tells me that they saw
the stuff coming well I simply refused
to believe you kite comes into this with
much of the same features that made
every other death on the sister surprise
it was a legacy character in fact not
only that but he was the very first
character ever seen in the series and
yes enemy only fans this is indeed true
because in the manga kite is the very
first character the we lay eyes upon but
kite also had this profound connection
to Jing and this mental like role were
gotten gone which was never really
resolved it felt more like kites
character arc had begun and then was
interrupted rudely I might add by a
certain FOP toe plus in this case kites
ability is very much played into the
impression I had of him surviving into a
much longer time period I mean just the
way crazy slots was set up had me
thinking that there was no way we'd be
parting with this character until we'd
seen most of the abilities I mean if not
all of the individual options but this
is just another great takashi device he
sets up intrigue and then uses that to
subvert expectations leaving us with a
very decapitated kite and seemingly no
hope for stopping the Chimera ant threat
it was a very very effective death
although just like our number-two
contender kite would not necessarily
stay dead as he would be reincarnated as
a chimera
and not just any ants mind you but mara
West win which really could lead him or
actually guess her now to attaining even
more incredible power than she had in
her previous life so it's another one of
those scenarios where toga she figured
out how to have his cake and eat it to
use the death of a major character to
phenomenal dramatic effect and still
have that character be a part of this
world not many authors could pull that
kind of crap off and that is why I
believe that kite serves as the number
one most shocking death in the entire
series but that pretty much does it for
the top five most shocking deaths in
Hunter hunter if you enjoyed this video
and the content this channel produce in
general then please do consider donating
to the New World review patreon because
the support of all of your amazing
people is what continues to make this
channel possible and if patreon isn't
quite your style then please do leave
this video a like share or subscribe
because it also helps for this channel
an incredible amount and if you'd like
to join the fun at any time and please
do head over to my discord server where
a wide array of shenanigan takes place
on a daily basis and finally please do
comment with the death that shocked you
most in Hunter hunter this has been the
new alt review and I'll see you next
time
[Music]
could we maybe get some you Hoffa sure
well cut take your hitman reborn videos
it's very hard to find reborn fans so
YuYu Hakusho I think is an inevitability
for the channel I mean with such a
strong focus on Hunter hunter I do think
that it makes sense to cover Takashi's
are the mega-hit series at least briefly
as for reborn though that's an
interesting question because that's a
series that I often forget exists
entirely
I remember reading reborn weekly when I
was in high school and I even cosplay
Yamamoto once it looked absolutely awful
but I did it I stopped reading it pretty
early on into the future out there and
forget exactly why but it just ended up
losing me I should probably go back and
finish it just to know how everything
played out but even if I did do that it
would probably take an ungodly amount of
time to make anything reborn related for
this channel if indeed anyone is
actually interested in me doing such a
thing
what Hogwarts house are you sorted into
so rather boring Lee the last time I
took such a quiz I believe I was placed
in a hoe buff which to the best of my
knowledge is the house for all of the
like leftovers girl you know the people
who want courageous enough being
Gryffindor smart enough to be in
Ravenclaw or evil enough to be in
Slytherin and you know I didn't think
that was so bad because I thought to
myself well at least her in the same
house as Luna Lovegood until my wife
pointed out to me that Luna was actually
in Ravan cool because Hufflepuff can
never have anything ever oh and fun fact
my wife was actually in two of the Harry
Potter films